MALE SPEAKER: Action.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
Good afternoon.
My name is Brian Fitzpatrick.
Most people call me Fitz.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
My name is Ben.
And we are in a new
location today.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: We're in
a new location with Google
Develop for Good.
And we've got some more people
to talk to you about it.
So let's get our first guest.
Hi, what's your name?
CAROLYN WENDELL: My name's
Carolyn Wendell.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And where
do you work at, Carolyn?
CAROLYN WENDELL: I work at
Google for Nonprofits.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: And you'll
tell us a little bit
more about this?
CAROLYN WENDELL: Yeah, sure.
[INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: We've
got to start over.
Can we change their line?
CAROLYN WENDELL: --streamline
their internal
operations as well.
And Google for Nonprofits, the
way that we really do this is
by providing nonprofits with
special tools to help them.
And so we provide them with
Google products either free of
charge, or sometimes
at reduced cost.
And so for example, one thing
that we have is the Google for
Nonprofits program.
And this allows US nonprofits to
really apply to a program,
where they have access
to exclusive
nonprofit product benefits.
So for example, a nonprofit
could use Google Apps free of
charge for up to 3,000 users.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Wow.
CAROLYN WENDELL: Yeah.
And they get premium Geo Tools
as well, such as Google Maps
API Premier, or Google
Earth Pro, for free.
We also offer Google AdWords
advertising, and some special
YouTube features, as well,
for nonprofits.
And that's all through the
Google for Nonprofits program.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So you guys
are all out to basically help
nonprofits and save
them money.
CAROLYN WENDELL:
Yeah, exactly.
And if they want to apply to
the Google for Nonprofits
program, it's really easy.
You just have to go to
google.com/nonprofits.
If you're a US nonprofit,
you can apply there.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And is that
like for 501(c)(3)s?
CAROLYN WENDELL: Exactly, yes.
You have to be a 501(c)(3).
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: So what is
the motivation for having a
booth here at our developer
conference today?
CAROLYN WENDELL: Oh, well, thank
you for asking that.
We're so excited to be here at
I/O today, because we all know
that developers want
to do good.
And we've had developers come up
to us who already have been
engaging with their nonprofits
in their local communities.
And really, we're here at I/O
just to learn more from
developers about what sort of
engagement they'd like to have
with nonprofits.
So if you're out there, and
you're interested in talking
to us about how you have helped
nonprofits, or maybe
how you might want to get
involved more in the future,
we'd love to come up
and hear from you.
We also are here because we
really want help promoting the
Google for Nonprofits and Google
for Nonprofits program,
and helping to educate other
nonprofits that you may know
about about our program, and
about how Google can help you
and help their cause.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So if
people out there in
internet-land want to know
more, where do they go?
CAROLYN WENDELL: Where should
they go if they want to know
more about Google
for Nonprofits?
Google.com/nonprofits, that's
where they want to go.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
That's fabulous.
Thanks so much for your time.
It was great having you on.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
Wonderful.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Take care.
Have a great conference.
CAROLYN WENDELL: Thank
you, guys.
Bye.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Bye, bye.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Let's
grab another person here.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: We have
another person here.
All right, who do
we have here?
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Hello.
What is your name?
TANYA BIRCH: My name
is Tanya Birch.
And I work on the Google
Earth Outreach team.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And tell
me a little bit more
about what is that.
What is Google Earth Outreach?
TANYA BIRCH: Yeah, so Google
Earth Outreach is a team
underneath the Geo, underneath
Google Earth.
We help nonprofits solve the
world's most pressing problems
using Google's mapping
technologies, whether it's in
the environmental sector, or
humanitarian, or crisis
response, or any
kind of sector.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Does this
involve working with a lot of
governments, then, I assume?
Or making--
Or is it-- ?
TANYA BIRCH: It's
more nonprofits
that are on the ground--
similar to what Carolyn
was talking about--
that are really implementing
solutions for environmental
issues, or humanitarian
issues on the ground.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So
what brings you guys
here to Google I/O?
What are you looking for
from developers?
TANYA BIRCH: I'm really excited
to be here at Google
I/O because we get a lot of
nonprofits who are always
coming to us, asking for help
creating interesting mapping
visualizations.
And we have a couple things.
We have a Developer
Grants program.
We also offer software
grants to nonprofits.
But we really, mainly, just
want to connect with
developers, because we know so
many NGOs that are out there
that need help building
their maps.
And so we want to put
the two together.
We have a Developer Marketplace
for nonprofits to
go and find developers.
It's sort of like a matchmaking
service, right?
If you're a developer,
and you want to do
something that's for good--
instead of for the man, or
whatever-- then you can list
yourself on the Developer
Marketplace.
And our URL is
earth.google.com/outreach.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Do you have
any particular examples
or success stories that
you can share with us?
TANYA BIRCH: Yeah, I do.
Let's see.
Probably my favorite one is, I
was just last week at Rio+20.
And the Surui Amazon indigenous
tribe launched
their cultural map.
So this is a tribe in the
Amazon Rainforest.
And they're struggling to
protect their land from
deforestation.
And also, they want to preserve
their culture in a
mapping environment.
They've created this cultural
map that's right now only on
big PDF version.
It's beautiful, but it's hanging
in their office.
So they created this cultural
map, that is now in Google
Earth, that everybody can see.
And they're also using Android
smartphones to engage, to
measure the carbon of their
trees in their rainforest, and
preserve their forest for
future generations.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And so
developers can join in and
help make that happen?
TANYA BIRCH: Organizations
like that are looking for
developers, exactly.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
Sounds like a
great way to get connected.
Wow, fantastic.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And what's
your second favorite?
Name one more.
I'll make you pick your favorite
children here.
TANYA BIRCH: It's tough, because
there are so many.
But probably my second favorite
is WWF and Eyes on
the Forest.
And they just launched
a Google Maps
Engine powered map.
It's eyesontheforest.or.id.
And it basically tracks rates
of deforestation, historical
rates of deforestation, in
Sumatera, and compares it to
animal habitats, like
rhinoceros, tiger, orangutan.
And you can see how as the
forest, the habitat, shrinks,
the ranges of the animals
shrink as well.
So it's eyesontheforest.or.id.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And have you
gotten a lot of interest
here at the I/O from people
you've been meeting at the
booth today?
TANYA BIRCH: Yeah, I mean, we
have a very, very close
relationship with both
developers and both the
nonprofits who we work with.
So it's great to be here,
because there's a lot of
excitement.
And we have, actually, a talk
tomorrow, "Maps for Good,"
where we're going to have two
of the developers who were
awarded Developer
Grants last year
speaking about their projects.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
That's fabulous.
So one last time, let's give
the URL, so everybody knows
where to go so they
can help out.
Because they're going to
do this right now.
TANYA BIRCH: It's
earth.google.com/outreach.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Excellent.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
Thank you so much.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
Thanks so much.
It's great meeting you.
All right.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: All right,
who else is here?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
OK, number three.
Here we go.
So who do we have here?
CHRISTIAAN ADAMS: Hi, my name's
Christiaan Adams.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And what
do you do, Christiaan?
CHRISTIAAN ADAMS: I'm with the
Crisis Response team out of
google.org.
And we are here talking to
developers about the various
tools that we make available to
help get information out in
times of crisis.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: All right, so
tell us a little more about
what Crisis Response does.
Exactly how do you guys work?
CHRISTIAAN ADAMS: Sure.
So when a disaster happens--
an earthquake, or a flood,
or a tornado, or
something like that--
the people affected, one
of their big needs is
information, like, where's
my family?
Are they OK?
Where are the shelters?
Do I need to evacuate?
If so, where?
And when people are looking for
information, they tend to
come to Google, because we're
pretty good at information.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: We have
a search engine.
CHRISTIAAN ADAMS: Yeah, we do.
And so we're trying to make the
kind of information that
people look for during times
of crisis easier to find,
access, and use.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Now, you
were giving me an example
earlier about New York City,
about just sometimes there's a
lack of serving power to
get information out.
Can you tell me a little
more about that?
CHRISTIAAN ADAMS: Sure.
When Hurricane Irene went up
the East Coast last year,
there were evacuation
maps that were--
I believe it was a 10 megabyte
PDF on somebody's website.
And of course, that server
didn't stand up very well to
the millions of people who were
trying to access that
information at that time.
So we helped by adding that map
information to one of our
tools, which is our Crisis
Mapping tool, and combined it
with many other layers, like the
radar, and the clouds, and
the evacuation routes, and the
flood stages from the USGS,
and a whole bunch of other
layers, and made that
available both through our
website, and made it easy for
the city to embed on their
website, and for news agencies
to embed on their websites.
And because it's running on our
data centers, we didn't
have a problem with the large
amount of users, the large
spike of users that you get
during those times.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Wow,
that's incredible.
CHRISTIAAN ADAMS: Yeah, we're
here talking to developers
about all those different tools,
and talking about the
open standards and the
web-friendly scalable data
formats that we encourage people
to publish data in, so
that they can be shared
and made accessible
during crisis times.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So how
can developers help out?
What can they do to help?
CHRISTIAAN ADAMS: So we touched
on our mapping tools.
They can publish things in
formats such as KML, or using
some of Google Tools, such as
Fusion Tables, or our new Maps
Engine tools.
And those are all ways to
publish map data in a way that
scales well, that can handle
the load, and that is
web-friendly.
Our maps work across mobile
and desktop seamlessly.
People can access them on the
go, because they may not be in
front of their desktop
when they're
responding to a disaster.
And we also have things like
our Person Finder tool.
So we have an open format there
that has helped bring
together the missing
persons databases.
And so that if you're looking
to see where your family is,
or if they're OK, or you want
to let your family know that
you're OK, there's one place you
can go in Person Finder to
share that information.
We encourage developers to use
that open source tool to
implement that and use the
open format there.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So you guys
are talking about bringing
people together in crisis,
and saving
families, and saving lives.
I mean, this is really
important stuff.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: But then
harvesting developers' power
to provide that information
into Google systems.
And it's really fantastic.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So if
I'm a developer out
there, how can I help?
Where do I go?
CHRISTIAAN ADAMS: You can
check out our website.
It's google.org/crisisresponse.
You'll see our various tools
up there, a whole list of
tools that responders can use,
tools for people impacted by
disasters, and links to some
of our previous responses.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: That
sounds really awesome.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: All right.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Another
place for everyone to go.
Thanks a lot.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Wonderful,
one more person here.
So what is your name?
FIONA LEE: My name's
Fiona Lee.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And what
do you work on, Fiona?
FIONA LEE: I work
on the Emerging
Markets team in Google.
Basically, we work on places
like Latin America,
Sub-Saharan Africa, Middle East,
North Africa, India, and
Southeast Asia.
So the developing parts
of the world.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And you're
here at I/O for Android for
Good, is that right?
FIONA LEE: That's correct.
Android for Good is a
donation program.
The goal is to reuse Android
phones by donating them to
nonprofits and to educational
institutions, so universities
in emerging markets.
If you have a working Android
phone and it is unlocked, you
should drop it off at the
Android for Good booth at I/O.
We also collect them
from Googlers from
offices around the world.
And we take the phones, we
wipe them of personal
information, we test
them to make sure
everything's working.
And then we donate them to
nonprofits that will use them
in the field, or to educational
institutions in
Africa, mostly, to teach
Android programming.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: And
how has this program
worked out so far?
Do you have any interesting
stories?
FIONA LEE: So we've had
two full years.
This is our third year.
We've collected about
450 phones.
And they were valued at probably
$400, $500 a piece
when they were donated.
So do the math.
A variety of nonprofits have
gotten those phones.
Probably the one that is closest
to my heart is one
called V-Day, which
is a nonprofit
founded by Eve Ensler.
She's a playwright
and activist.
She wrote The Vagina
Monologues.
I don't know if you can
say that on the air.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: It's
the internet.
It's OK.
FIONA LEE: OK, so they use those
phones and work with
Panzi Hospital in the Democratic
Republic of Congo.
In the DRC, rape is a really
huge problem for women.
And so this hospital does a
lot of work with women who
have been raped.
And they use the phones and
document the stories of the
rape, and to capture the history
so that if there
should ever be a time when
justice is served, and we have
trials, the perpetrators can
be brought to justice.
So that's probably my favorite
use of the phone,
the donation program.
The second one is--
and this one has scaled
really, really well--
a nonprofit called VETAID that
works in Kenya and Tanzania.
They use the phones to basically
track animal disease
and vaccination programs.
And they use a data collection
tool called EpiCollect.
It's built on top
of App Engine.
It's open source.
And they do a lot of work
to track droughts.
For example, when Kenya had a
really bad drought last year,
they tracked all that because,
for people in the Rift Valley,
your animals are your
livelihood.
It's been so successful that
the Food and Agriculture
Organization, Veterinarians
Without Frontiers, the Gates
Foundation are now using this
tool to do animal surveillance
and disease monitoring
for all of Africa.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So
you're saying, any
Android unlocked phone.
So I've got an old unlocked G1
that's like 50 years old.
Could you guys do anything
with that?
FIONA LEE: I would prefer to
have more recent phones.
But if they're unlocked and they
work, and you have the
charger, hand it over.
And we don't have a website,
unfortunately.
This is a 20% project and a
labor of love with a lot of
help from other Googlers.
So you can just email me,
flee@google.com--
flee@google.com.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: OK,
so that's great.
I mean, that sounds
really good.
450 phones, and you've just been
working like 20% time?
FIONA LEE: Yeah.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So this is
you and some other engineers,
and other folks, or other
companies within the company?
FIONA LEE: We have points of
contact in all the Google
offices around the world.
And so this is a team effort.
And then we use a local company
here to wipe the data,
and to donate it and
all that stuff.
So it's all above board.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: All right,
so if anyone out there has a
phone that they wanted to give
to Android for Good, they can
email flee--
flee@google.com.
And you will make sure that
it gets somewhere and does
something good.
Is that right?
FIONA LEE: You got it, yep.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: That's
fabulous, excellent.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN:
It's fantastic.
Thank you so much.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Wow,
this is amazing.
15 minutes of four incredible
projects
that people are doing.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: If you are
a developer, you can make
a real impact on the world,
not just make money.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Not
just work for the--
I think Tanya said, work
for the man, right?
Like we do.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: I
resemble that remark.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
That's great.
Well, I think now we're
going to wrap up.
And we're going to turn things
back over to the next session.
We'll see you guys, I think, in
another hour or so, when we
have some other interesting
people to talk to.
See you then.
Thanks a lot.
BEN COLLINS-SUSSMAN: Bye, bye
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Bye, bye.